So I'm really excited
we're live on YouTube,
if you were here for
the candy pre-show.
You're welcome.
That was unexpected
treat for everybody.
This spooky season,
but good morning.
Good afternoon and I am
so excited to have you
all here with us today
as we kick off our hiring
great data science teams panel.
My name is Jesse mackowiak
and while I am currently
a developer advocate with the
Shiny team here at studio,
not that long ago, I was
a data science job seeker
who eventually got their first
data science job before moving
into data science management.
So I know that we have a lot
of ground to cover today with
our panelists, and I cannot
wait for them to have
the opportunity to share their
advice and experiences with
you.
So we have four
fantastic panelists today
we'll be hearing from
Rhonda great, principal data
scientist at Boeing
and adjunct professor
at Washington State University.
We have Katie Shaffer, who
is the manager of advanced
analytics at the
dental software,
is director of quantitative
analytics at Pandora and eui
sun VP of analytics at Amwell.
So really an incredible,
incredible panel
with a ton of advice and
experience, and please
feel free to put your
questions in chat.
We do have a list of
prepared questions,
but as always, we would love
to hear from you as well.
So to kick things
off, all of you
come from data
science backgrounds,
and I'm really curious
how that experience has
helped inform your ability to
manage a data science team.
So I'll throw that
over to you first.
Oh, sure.
So I my background
is in statistics,
that's what I went to
graduate school for
and that was a really
natural transition.
So one of my first jobs
out of grad school.
The title is senior analyst.
I was working with health care
data and the responsibilities
and tasks, you know,
involved our skill working
with large databases, you
know, doing analyses, basically
all of the range of skills you
would expect a data scientist
to have today.
So you know, that
experience, of course,
was helpful to understand
the technical side.
But I think just
like any other job
where that's data
scientists or I
don't know marketing associate
anything the biggest and most
important part in terms
of getting to where I was
is learning how a business
functions and just
the day to day
operations, you know,
understanding the importance
of emotional intelligence,
working with other people, being
organized, paying attention
to process.
So those are, I think, more
important than the actual data
science technical
jobs themselves.
So it's just really
being open and curious
as most as all data scientists
are to those other aspects
of the job.
Rhonda, how about you?
I'd love to hear how, you know,
coming from a data background
has influenced your
management style.
Sure my management style
are the first three,
so I'm not
technically a manager.
I'm an associate
technical fellow,
which is a slightly different
role than management.
We really take on the technical
responsibilities of the team
and guiding technical
vision for execution.
But I'll just kind of add to
my background is in statistics
and I have a Navy cat right now,
so I might just hold her here
because otherwise she'll
just keep jumping up here
and my I have an undergraduate
and a graduate degree
in anthropology, actually, which
is really different than most
people in this field.
And what it especially like
my anthropology degree, what
happens is it just
makes me realize
the importance of
diversity on the team
because people with
different backgrounds
and different skills, whether
you're from statistics,
US economics or, you know,
environmental science,
everybody brings a unique
perspective to solving
real problems, right?
And how we do that with data.
And so really, that's kind of
what I look for in a team is,
you know, do we have
different set of skills?
How can we bring those
skills and methodologies
to solve problems that we have?
Jarvis, how about you?
Can you tell us a bit
about your background
and how that helps inform
managing a data science team?
Yeah, definitely.
So I came up through the
team that I now manage,
so I started as an
analyst on that team
and sort of worked my way up
to be in charge of it now.
And I think the biggest
thing is that when you've
done the work yourself, it
gives you a very, I think,
good idea of how to ask
people to do that work.
And I try to be sort
of like the boss.
Like, I think it's easy
for me to ask myself,
like, what was my ideal
boss when I was an analyst?
And then how do I
try to become that?
And I think it works
well when you've
done the work, because that
vision tends to be more aligned
with something that's achievable
and good for the business.
But when you're
managing people and you
don't share those
experiences, it's
a lot harder to one formulate
what that good boss looks like
and then also to become it.
And in some cases, it may be
almost unreasonable, right?
If you're in charge of a bunch
of different groups of teams
that sort of
competing priorities,
you may need to
make decisions that
benefit one over the other.
But having done the
work and then having
been in charge of
the small team,
I think I have a very good
idea of what it entails
and also how to make sure
that it's communicated well
and it maximizes impact.
So sort of being
the person I wanted
to have when I was doing
it as how I go about it,
I think it's worked
pretty well so far,
but that's sort of my strategy.
Yeah cool.
And then I guess, yeah,
from my perspective,
I would kind of echo
everything everyone just said.
I'd say some ads
there would be coming
from a PhD program or academia.
I think I'm more
sensitive on the hiring
front to the skill
set that they bring,
even though oftentimes they will
lack an actual job experience
outside of academia.
Just thinking through their
experience as job experience
is really important, and I
think that can be valuable skill
sets to the team.
But then also knowing
kind of the skill
gaps that they'll
come with, right,
since they have not worked in
more of an industry setting.
And then I think one thing I
didn't appreciate in my old job
that I do appreciate
in my new job.
So my old job, I was
a data scientist.
There was no really
analytics team
was more of a consulting firm.
My new job, I started out
managing the analytics team.
So I think finally, I've
gotten kind of a full circle
lens of how those two
teams can really complement
one another, data science and
analytics, the differences
and kind of the complementary
nature between the two.
Yeah so I'd say that
definitely informs
my hiring of data
scientists knowing, hey,
where do we want to take
and pick up some of the work
that the analysts have done?
And how will those two teams
and to folks work together so?
Yeah, that's really great.
You've kind of queued up
for this next question,
so I'm going to start
with you, Katie.
But I'd really love to hear.
I know that everyone watching
has questions about this,
and I know we all have
experience with this,
but certainly with
Katie, how do you feel
or what do you feel are the best
ways to assess a candidate's
technical ability?
Yeah, so a lot of different
options for this, of course.
I think my goal is a hiring
manager is just again
to your first question, right?
Having done the work yourself
to at least some degree,
I think, allows you to just
assess in some of their answers
do they know what
they're talking about
or is there kind of a level of
are they reaching a little bit
too far on some of the skills?
So I think that my technical
experience helps with that.
But I think one thing
we do here at beam
is we have a take home
test, a simulated data.
I think it is really
important to assess
those technical skills
in an interview.
But I think the one thing
that I'm really not a fan of
is kind of to a
point, I think certain
more traditional like
whiteboarding or brainteaser
questions and interviews.
I think at a certain
point, they kind
of just measure
performance under duress
versus performance.
So I think there's a happy
medium between whether you're
doing kind of a live technical
interview, live coding,
making that productive and worth
the time in terms of assessing
the skills you want to assess.
Take home is certainly another
route that I become a fan of,
but I've seen the kind of more
live technical interviews done
well and then some maybe not
so well where folks might have
missed out on some
good candidates
just because they asked a brain
teaser that the person didn't
get in those five minutes.
So that's kind of my quick take.
And I'll kind of follow up.
I say I'm a huge fan
of them basically
talking about what
they're passionate about
and describing situations where
they've actually applied it
and some of the key criteria
you know that we probably
look for in some of those
answers are like, you know,
somebody coming up to you and
asking you for advice on how
to solve these problems, right?
Are you being a mentor
to somebody else?
Because that's usually
a way that you can share
your skills with somebody else.
That means you're
confident enough
to demonstrate your
skills and then share
that with somebody else and
and basically teach, right?
Also, your know, your
ability to describe it
in a technical manner and
a situation in which you
applied it.
Because honestly,
like, you know,
people come from a variety
of different backgrounds,
there's a whole bunch
of different language
that different backgrounds use
to describe the same processes.
And so, you know, I
really like the approach
of asking them to describe a
situation that they've been in.
What was the outcome of
that and really describe
the result in a technical
format in you can usually
tell when somebody is
passionate about something
and let them kind of pursue
their passions a little bit,
but at the same time,
making sure that the skills
that we need for the job, right?
I agree a technical exercise
is really important.
I've always used
them, it's, you know,
it's really the only way you can
quickly and accurately assess
the technical skills.
So I think it's
required also just,
you know, the basic
integrating and job
seeking 101
expectations, you know?
Well, put together resume.
Of course, no typos,
things like that.
Things they teach you
over and over again.
And then over time,
at least, I like
to think I've developed
like an intuition also.
You know, it's well,
it's more than intuition.
It's, you know,
it's on the resume.
It's also in the actual
interview process themselves.
You can start to
assess to the extent
that person's really curious
and passionate about the work
itself.
So curiosity is pure
curiosity and energy
to me are my number, number one
and two traits that I look for.
You know, if you've only
learned how to write are on the,
you know, for a couple of
years or in grad school,
I think you can pick
those things up,
but you can't you
can't teach someone
to be really curious and
really energetic, you know?
Yeah and then
finally, when we do
start having
technical discussions,
I think this is reflected
in what Rhonda said.
You know, it's a matter
of does this person know
what they're talking about?
And so I listen for,
are they being specific
in what they're describing?
If they start speaking in
generalities and, you know,
vague answers, you
know, pretty quickly,
they don't really they
aren't really well suited
for this kind of job.
For sure, Yeah.
I'm an echo, a lot of
things that were said,
I'm on team take
home as well, and I
hate doing brain
teasers and interviews
or even asking
people to do them.
It's I don't know, it feels
like torture a lot of the time.
But a plea for hiring
managers out there, you know,
try to make sure
that you're asking
sort of as little
of folks that you
can to get a good
assessment on them
to just be respectful
of their time.
Because what happens is and I
think it works in your favor
because you have some very
bright folks out there who
are like, hey, you
know, I don't know
if I need to invest
$4 hours into this
when I have two offers.
So you're going
to turn away folks
who really do know what they're
doing if you make it to sort
of heavy and the opposite
logic, which I don't agree
with as well, if
they really cared,
they would sink in all
the time and energy,
and I just don't
agree with that.
But for us, you
know, I think there's
a big concern that,
well, what if they get
a lot of help on the take home?
You're not really
assessing their ability.
So we like to ask a lot
of follow up questions
during the interviews,
and we'll usually
use one of our
interviews to say,
OK, you made this decision
here, you made this choice
or using this technique.
Can you tell me a
little more about it?
And then we're doing what
you said of, you know,
is this something that
your friend told you to do
and you have no idea how
the technique works and you
can't answer questions?
Or is it something that
you have knowledge of?
So that's how we sort of try
to bring that all together
in our interview process.
Now, that's really interesting.
A lot of great, great
perspectives here,
and we've had a question
from the audience that really
dovetails nicely with this.
So I'd be really curious
if you change the way
that you assess
a candidate based
on their kind of
educational background.
So, for example,
data science degrees
are now a thing
that people can get.
But if someone comes from
a quantitative background,
computer science
statistics, data science
versus someone coming from just
a non quantitative background,
education or policy
or literature,
do you change how you assess
that individual in an interview
or no, maybe everybody's a
no, but I'd be really curious
if there's anything
how you kind of May
approach that
differently, if at all.
I'd say that the first
thing that sticks out to me
is a little bit
less of what I do,
kind of where the
conversation heads,
but to me, it's really important
you, whatever your applicant
management system is, it's
really important that you're
keeping up with the recruiting,
like the lead recruiter on it
to make sure that person
gets an interview.
That's what I found to be the
most crucial way in which I
step in which I typically
wouldn't is just
giving the head recruiter that
like commenting when we see
the application and seeing
stupor on top of it myself,
because it's a little bit
harder sometimes for them
to spot like, oh,
well, this person
with this nontraditional
background
has the skills you want or not.
So I just make sure that I get
a chance to talk to that person
if I see that they've got
some components that are maybe
nontraditional, but
speak to their skill set.
And I'll kind of
add that as somebody
who comes from a more
nontraditional state
background.
I graduated with a
liberal arts degree.
And then I got my start degree.
But I will say like personally,
as I entered job interviewing,
I was worried that my
anthropology degree
would actually set me back.
But the reality,
I mean, it still
had to start like, I still
have a master's in stats.
But the reality is it brought an
element that differentiated me
from the candidates.
And I will say at Boeing,
everybody gets the same.
Opportunity of interview for
that, that so everybody gets
the same question, so
as far as that goes,
that that's a standardized
process that our HR has
developed, right?
But I would encourage
like any people that
just have a solid like
science background
to go out and discover the
liberal arts because it
can only make you better.
Right?
that's my personal view,
and I love that, right?
So if you're coming from
a quantitative background,
go out, discover
do things outside
of your educational background.
So this really ties
into a question,
and I'd love to start with you.
Jerry's skills like
empathy and communication
are often mentioned
is like absolute
must haves for data scientists.
But how do a candidate
has these skills?
Yeah, I went through this great
training at work a while ago,
and it was sort of a
generalist training,
it was not for hiring
technical roles,
it was just hiring in
general, and they went over
a really good framework for
asking behavioral questions.
And what I thought
was so unusual
about it was that, like
the questions to me,
seemed to have obvious answers.
But if you ask 10 people
or 10 data scientists,
you're going to get
rid of three of them
because they're not
going to give you
the answer that you would want.
And so what we do
is we ask these,
we put them in situations
that are sort of undesirable.
And I don't mean literally
in the interview.
I mean, we asked
them about situations
that are undesirable.
You know, you've gotten a vague
request from a stakeholder
and we see how they deal
with those situations.
And I think folks who deal
well with that first say,
OK, you know, I get that
this happens on the job
and I will work with them
to come to an answer.
But there's always a subset of
folks who kind of put it back
on you and is like, well,
isn't your job to prevent
these things from happening?
Or like, why would I
be in this position?
And it's, you know,
as much as I'd
love to live in a world
in which it never happens,
it always happens.
And so it's kind of an easy way.
I found to ask those
behavioral questions
about difficult situations that
involve working with people
or communicating
things to people
and seeing sort of how flexible
data scientists applicants can
be in their answers.
So it was funny to me because
when I first learned these,
I'm like, well, no one's
going to say like, I shouldn't
do that or that's not
my job, but you end up
picking up a few people who
genuinely do feel that way.
And and, you know,
I'm sure they're
a great fit for
another role out there.
But but that role
isn't one of is.
Yeah, for sure, it's
and it's kind of
nice to get to that
point where, you know,
like you don't want to
pull a candidate along
if they're not a good fit.
So as we're talking
about hiring,
I I'd love to hear from
you to kick things off
in terms of how do you know
when it's time to grow your data
science team and kind
of to piggyback off
of that, what strategies do
you employ when you're growing
your team?
Of everywhere I've been.
It's always, well,
I've always been
hired because they
needed to grow the team,
so they hired me
to grow the team.
So it's the answer is
always pretty much most,
you know, for most
firms that are
data rich obviously could stand
to use more data scientists.
But, you know, to answer
your question directly,
it's really a matter
of demand, right?
Less I've been doing
this for a long time,
and we just never have enough
data scientists, the type
of teams that I've managed.
I've always been internal
support and external support,
supporting clients and
supporting other functions
like marketing, sales,
operations, et cetera.
So the appetite for data
is, you know, bottomless.
So we're always in growth mode.
And then when it comes to
actually building out the team,
which I'm currently in
the situation, you know,
I really want to
try to build out
a team that's diverse in all
aspects, you know, technically
and experience wise.
You know, there is no such
thing as a data scientist
who can do everything.
I also don't want to have a data
scientist where everyone has
the exact same set of skills.
So you may have people who are
more experienced with the data
engineering side,
people who are more
experienced on the statistical
modeling side, et cetera.
In terms of experience,
you know, having people
from different backgrounds
in terms of degrees, that's
a great thing because they
bring different skill sets
and people from different
industries, you know,
because that allows, you know?
Everyone brings
their best practices,
and we can learn, at
least from each other,
learn and grow from each other.
And that's how I've done
that, that's how I've done it,
and it's worked well so far.
I really love that
statement that everybody
brings their best
practices, I think
that that's just
such a wonderful way
to think about growing a team.
So I would also really
love to hear from folks.
We have a question from the
audience around managers
staying in the code.
So in other words, what are
your thoughts and feelings
about management
and being a manager?
And should a manager still be
able to rate and review code
as well as solve
technical questions?
If you're at a startup.
Yes yeah, I've flamed out
a few times, a few startups
and you know, not surprisingly,
your short staffed,
so you're expected to pitch in.
But in my experience, this
is just my experience only
in health care.
You know, once you go
beyond the director level,
I think it's important
for the manager
to actually be the one
while managing because.
Uh, again, this goes
back to my firm belief
that process is
really important,
you know, you can't
just have people just
running around doing
whatever they want to do,
you have to steer the ship.
Everyone in the right direction,
it's a lot of work, you know?
Get, I can still read our,
you know, a little bit,
but, you know, I won't be nearly
as efficient as the people who
actually much
better at it, so you
don't want me writing the code.
Instead, you want
me going out there.
You want your manager
going out there in
and think of it this way,
finding more business
for the team.
Because finding more
business for the team,
whether it's
internal or external,
means more opportunities
for you to do other things.
You know, working in
other subject areas
add additional technical skills.
So that's how I think
that's how I view myself.
I'll kind of add, because
I'm not a manager, right?
But that's one of the great
and awesome things about Boeing
is we kind of have
different career paths
so you can go into
management or you
can be just a really
awesome employee,
or you can go into the
technical fellowship, which
is a career path driven
towards technical excellence.
And like, like I'm an air
Boeing designated expert, right?
There's not very many of
those at the Boeing company.
And so that's awesome.
Like I can help you
program and management
can really focus
on those more air
and going out and getting
the business things
while at the same time,
technical Fellows also
can kind of participate in
that, going out and getting
the business and where the
technical vision and things
like that are.
And so I think I
like Boeing for that
because if you really want to
focus on technical excellence,
you can really drive your
career in that direction
and you don't necessarily
have to end up in management.
It's all in.
Yeah, that's great.
And with that being
said, though, managers
should still be data literate.
That's a.
I love it, I love the
enthusiasm Katie and Jerry
has anything to add on that.
A lot of nodding, so I'm not
sure for all like, yeah, this,
I agree with this.
Or maybe someone is
like, no, absolutely.
Managers should be
coding every day.
I think it really, just
like others have said,
depends on the stage
of the company.
So I think at a certain point
it while it sounds nice,
I think it'd be fun.
It can be unrealistic to
expect that somebody who's
managing multiple
different teams or folks
has the time to program
considerably every day.
But I do think you need to
have a level of competency
and ideally you have had
experience in the role
or akin to the role
in your history
because I think if you don't
have enough experience,
it can be hard to
spot the root cause
of some like personnel issues
or maybe other friction
you're experiencing.
Because if you can't go
in and assess the issues
with the code or
the performance,
it'll be hard for you
as a manager to do that.
But at a certain
point, hopefully you've
staffed up a successor who
is able to do that for you,
so you can focus on the other
kind of higher level things
in terms of where are
we taking the team?
What kind of projects
are we taking on?
But for me, it is important
that I do write code from time
to time, especially as
projects are kicking off.
But certainly, I
think it depends
on where you're at in terms
of whether that should
be a daily thing or
you should be actually
moving projects
forward yourself.
But I think having
that skill set is
important to make sure your
team is functioning properly
and you're hiring
the right people.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I love this
emphasis on, you know,
you've mentioned where if
you're starting a project,
you're much more
involved with code
and you mentioned a lot about
the stage of the organization.
So I kind of want to
pivot a little bit
and I'll throw it
to Jerry's first.
But I want to talk
about something
that, at least on social media,
I think it's a lot of play
and that is about hiring
someone with the potential
to learn and grow.
So we see a lot of
advice from things
like I don't need 100% of the
requirements or I only meet 60%
And so you'll see next
advice from things
like, oh, as long as you meet
50 percent, you should apply
or it doesn't even
matter, just apply for it.
Like just go for it.
And then see people
were like, no, you've
got to be able to
do 80% or 90% So
when we're thinking about hiring
someone with the potential
to learn and grow.
How do you assess
this in a candidate?
Yeah, that's a great
that's a great question,
I think almost everybody is
in this boat where they're not
matching all of the criteria
that have been laid out.
So if the company does,
indeed box number seven
does indeed need that.
Like, you have to convince
them that this is something
I can pick up over time.
I think one of the
best indicators
is just a track record of
having done this in the past.
So when you're positioning
yourself for the role,
if you can look at prior
experience and say,
I did this role and
I didn't have xyz,
but these are things that I
picked up in the context of it.
I think that's a really
strong, you know,
you're showing that
I've done this before
and I'm looking to do it again.
So that's the best way I've
seen a position because you
do have a lot of candidates
who say, yeah, I'll pick it up,
but only a subset of
them are like, here's
sort of my track record
of having done this
in the past and prior roles
or in school or what have you.
Yeah, I think actually
school is a good example
as well because you have folks
who need to learn a programming
language to do a
specific project
and so they can bring
that to light as well.
But I think showing that track
record is really effective
because it goes beyond saying,
you know, trust me, I'll do it.
But like, trust me, I'll do it
because I've done it before.
I would add to like if
the candidate express
any interest in
continuing education
programs at the company.
Right so Boeing offers a lot of
continuing education programs.
And so if you're like really
interested in learning
and expanding one
area, say like, oh, I'm
really interested in
geospatial data science, right?
Because there's not a lot
of opportunities for that.
Maybe when you went
to school or whatnot.
And maybe that was one of the
small things on the resume.
And you're like, hey, do you
offer any internal programs
towards this or somewhere
where I could learn and expand
that particular skill?
I always look for those kind of
opportunities in an interview
to.
I'd love to hear
from other panelists.
I think my challenge
is doing this
for more junior candidates,
where often there isn't
that experience, so you
kind of have to go off
of how they answer things.
If anybody's found
a magic bullet,
I'd love to hear from it.
But I think that can be the
most challenging spot for me
is when somebody is junior.
You don't necessarily
have the expectation
that they would have had that
experience because you're
hiring a junior role.
To me, those are the
biggest blind spots
other than kind of how they
approach the project, how
they answer questions.
You have kind of
the least amount
to go off of to know,
OK, I know this person is
going to need a lot of
support when they start.
But how do I get more
reassurance that six months
from their starting months
from their starting point,
they're going to be one
of those people who's
just kind of self-sufficient.
So kind of an ass comes in.
Maybe it's more vague.
They will develop that
kind of more harder
to find a skill set of managing
and kind of doing things
from start to
finish on their own.
I think that can be a
little more challenging
for the junior folks.
Oh, go ahead, yes, please.
I just had a real
quick thing I saw
someone do during an
interview that stood out,
which is when you talk
about concepts or techniques
that the person is not
familiar with, people
with that sort of growth
mindset will make a note
and engage with
you more and say,
I want to learn more
about this later.
Some other folks, you know,
they get really embarrassed.
I don't know that, and they try
to steer the conversation away.
And I thought it was impressive
when someone both admits to me,
I hadn't heard of that, and
I will go, look it up later.
And then sometimes you
get the follow up email,
hey, I read about this like
so that really stood out
to me as a positive
behavior that I think
indicated the potential
for growth in the future
and the interest as well.
I'll throw it to you.
Sure Thanks.
A couple of things.
I think everyone who applies
to be a data scientist at least
has one thing they're
more comfortable with.
You know, so whether
it's against statistics
or programming in one
language versus another.
You know, I ask them
about that and how
they came about to
pick up those skills.
It's also you can see
it also on their resumes
and in their conversations
to, you know, like,
hey, I stumbled upon
this because, you know,
I was a graduate
student in this field
and I started
doing data analysis
and I realized this
is what I want to do.
Not, you know, x engineering.
I don't want to pick on
a particular engineering,
but you know, you
know, you know,
somebody in x engineering field
does a lot of data analysis
and realize their
passion is in data.
So tell me what specifically
about it, you know,
do you like the
programming part?
Everyone has a
thing that they're
pretty good at better
than the other,
the other aspects
of data science
and/or they're much more junior.
I ask about, you
know, their interests
outside of data science.
What's what's the
thing that you love
doing ballet dancer cooking?
You know, there's
always disciplines
that transfer really
well, because in my mind,
it's about process and practice.
I don't I don't see data
science as any different.
It's process and practice.
I will just add kind of
quickly from my experience
as being an adjunct professor.
And it is interesting moving
from like this graduate frame
of mind to the fact
that, you know,
certain universities are now
offering undergraduate degrees
in data analytics.
And the breadth and
experience is a lot smaller.
It's a lot smaller
of a window, right?
Teaching a senior capstone
class is really giving me
insight on how students
actually think about these
and then thinking
about how does that
translate when they go and
try to interview for a job?
Because, you know, obviously,
like most of them, probably
just went through the general
education requirements and then
the last two or three
semesters of school,
they were really cramming
in like all these kind
of analytics classes,
they don't know
how to describe a logistic
regression to you.
You know, they're
like, they're just,
you know, really starting at
that very fundamental phrase.
And I will say,
like, I enjoy also
mentoring the students
because in the capstone class,
we spend some time
talking about how
do you do interviewing strategy,
especially like on your resume.
You were, you know, a like
you worked at the deli,
at Safeway or something.
Right and so I talk
about really expand
on that experience working at
the deli counter, you know,
talk about were
employee in the month.
Why were you employee
of the month, right?
Really accentuate
those skills and talk
about your areas and
passion of why you picked
this major to begin with?
And then how can you
apply those to this job
if you're given the
opportunity to do that?
And that's usually
just general advice
they give the students
because, yeah,
it has been enlightening
seeing it from both ends.
So, yeah, absolutely.
And I think something
that everyone's touched on
is this idea of being able to
articulate what skills you have
and how they translate
to data science.
So not all of your skills
have to be in data science,
but they do still relate to
your ability to do data science.
And related to that,
we have a question
about thinking about
candidates and how,
if at all you whathe or
non-technical contributions
to the broader data
science community,
whether that's through social
media, blogging, YouTube
tutorials, anything
that a candidate does,
that's maybe kind
of in this amorphous
they're not doing
it for work, they're
doing it because they're
really curious and passionate.
Does that come into play
for you when analyzed
or kind of deciding
on a candidate?
And if so, how?
But for me.
I mean, it's to me, their
social media interactions are,
you know, things they do on
their own time, which is great.
And I don't think
it has any bearings
on theatrical applications, so.
So, you know, do I think
they can do the job or not?
I'd say I have a slightly
different perspective.
I'd say at the end
of the day, my focus
is definitely can they
do the job or not?
So it's not a
requirement by any means.
I feel like I've
hired great folks who
don't have some sort of blog
or data science side hustle.
But it is a plus when I
see that because to me,
I think what I do care about
is that you are depending
on the level, if you're a more
senior candidate that you are
going to be staying on top of
what is new and new packages
and new trends, new
programs, new methods, right?
Like if I'm hiring you for
doing NLP analysis like
that, space is
changing so constantly,
it would be impossible to think
that one person could keep up
with that and all the
different things, right?
So if that's what you're
going to be a specialist in.
I think it's a great plus to
show your hunger for that.
But I think I've
definitely seen folks
who demonstrate that
hunger and that kind of up
to speed with current state
who maybe don't have a blog
or don't run a chapter of pi
Ladies or Ladies or something.
So I think it's
a big plus, but I
think you can demonstrate
it in other ways.
So that's how I view it.
And I'll just add,
like, you know,
at Boeing, we're not
necessarily allowed
to participate in certain
things and say, I always just
want to add like
other hiring people.
Sometimes that should weigh in
as part of the consideration
as well.
But with that being
said, especially like
if you're working in a
research and technology branch,
I would expect
you to participate
in professional associations.
Right especially like as part
of the technical fellowship,
some of it is like your
external connections
and how people are looking
at you technically,
but that is like at a level of
technical excellence, right?
Versus I just like
to write and blog.
So I would say, like
during our interview,
I can't really give
you an answer to how
that weighs at Boeing.
I would just say that
sometimes just consider
that maybe those people are not
actually allowed to participate
in those channels as well.
Yeah to add to this, this is
a really tricky one for me
because as much as I think
it's fair to say you have
the person showing
passion, they're
showing the ability to
maybe build communities
or to engage in a broader
sense and data science.
I don't want to create a
world in which future data
scientists feel like
they need to have a blog
or they need to have
an active social media
because some people have
no interest in doing that.
And I think they should be able
to get data science positions
without having to do it.
So I haven't had a lot of
candidates cross my desk
that do have, hey, check out
like my data science Twitter.
Personally, I enjoy
them, but I would just
hate to pick someone over
someone else because, you know,
someone is sort of
more naturally inclined
to do that sort of
work than someone else.
And then, of course, it depends
on the quality of the work.
I think something
as simple as like,
I have a friend who
works for a large tech
company in advertising and every
week explains an advertising
term to all of his
followers, many of whom
don't work in advertising.
And I thought that was a really
cool, simple way of teaching
folks more about sort of the
ecosystem that he works with.
He's in sales, so
it probably helps
him generate more, but just
a really small, elegant way
to show like, I have knowledge.
And I want to share
it with the community,
and it doesn't seem like
too much of a heavy lift.
I don't think he's
applying, but if he was,
I feel like that's
something he could bring up.
And maybe that's a
lighter weight way
of demonstrating that
you have the ability
to communicate and participate.
Yeah, really, grab this.
Go ahead.
No, no, no, go ahead.
Oh, I'm really glad this
topic is being discussed.
I agree with Katie that, you
know, it's important for people
to stay up to date.
You know, I love
Twitter because, you
know, I'm an avid follower
of folks on, you know,
stats, Twitter or Twitter,
machine learning, Twitter
or whatever.
You know, so to speak.
Stay up to date and find
resources there, for sure.
So this is more of a.
Cautionary point in that I
also see a lot of data science
enthusiasts on Twitter who
I don't know if this is true
or not, I worry that they're
learning data science
or stats too much from Twitter.
There's only so
many things you can.
There's only so much
you can learn from.
Was it 280 characters
I can't remember?
know?
And you really have, you
know, this is a slow skill
that you have to acquire with
hard work, not a fast skill
that you can just
pick up with tweets.
You know, Twitter is great for
finding links and, you know,
to longer blogs or resources.
But you know, I would
not substitute AI.
I follow this 2020 thread
and now I know, you know,
x skill, right?
That's just not going to happen.
I think these are all fantastic.
This is there's a lot of
really great advice in here,
and I think social
media is very rewarding,
but it's also like that
quick kind of reward,
and I love this idea of thinking
about using social media
as a starting place.
There is an inspiration, but
to make sure you're doing.
Don't let the underlying work of
learning to be a data scientist
and continue growing your
data science skill set.
Suffer for your social media.
This is very hard for
me to say as someone
who lives on social media.
But yes, do the work.
Social media is like
the candy later.
So I do.
There's one question we're
going to drastically shift gears
a little bit because
I really, really,
really want to make sure that
we get a chance to answer this.
And Katie, I would
love to start with you.
I would love to know
how you think about
and define the
differences between a data
analyst and a data scientist.
Yeah, so I'm sure
this looks different.
A lot of places, but one
kind of division of skills
that's resonated for me.
So from a technical perspective,
if I think of where,
like our analysts
versus data scientists
are spending their time,
I think a lot of analysts
are spending and tend to be a
little bit stronger on the SQL.
Typically, just to be honest
in the industry BI tools.
So Tableau look or power bi,
and then my ideal analyst
would also be able to
dabble in Python or r,
so they'd be able to pick up
our Python for some deeper
analysis when they need to.
I've come to realize when I
got out of consulting, though,
that a lot of times they're
super strong in scale.
They do a lot of that in SQL,
but we found opportunities
for doing something in R or
Python instead when that's
the better tool for the job.
And I'd say from
a job perspective,
analysts tend to be just have
a greater variety of projects
going on that tend to be
more focused around business
problems and kind of maybe more
qualitative post hoc analysis
versus forward looking models.
To contrast with the data
scientist R and Python
like strong expertise
in one of those
is a must versus kind
of a nice to have
or a will teach it as we go.
The background in
statistics is also crucial.
I think some kind of foundations
are crucial for an analyst,
but I wouldn't necessarily
expect an analyst
to be extremely
deep just in the way
that I would expect a
data scientist to maybe
be apt for sitting in on a
bunch of business meetings
across a variety of areas and
answering a variety of one
off questions.
The data scientist times
should be more focused
on protected on
specific projects.
And so it's to me from a
skill set perspective that
stat statistics training our
Python high level of competency
that kind of set things apart
and a little slightly less kind
of forward facing with multiple
different kind of stakeholders
from a business perspective.
So I will say my first
job as a data analyst
because there was no
title data scientist
and I did the same exact
thing in all honesty,
but with that being said
at the Boeing company,
it would probably come up as
a programmer, analyst job kind
of what Katie was describing.
And so I think it's
really important
to not necessarily pay
attention to the title,
but really read what
the job description is,
is saying and ask
questions when you
get an interview
about the job itself.
Because, yeah, it just
there's so much variety
and like you could be a research
analyst at Amazon or something,
for example, right?
So yeah, if I can chime in
here, like I don't know who's
asking the question, they might
be a job seeker, but you know,
I can give my definitions.
But unfortunately, when a
lot of people in the industry
don't adhere to a strict
definition of one or the other,
I think the most important thing
to do when looking for jobs
is what, as Rhonda said,
what does the job entail
and not just what's
written, but ask follow UPS
because sometimes
they say you're
going to be doing seven
things, but it's really
two of those seven things
that you're going to be doing.
And so try to narrow in on
that sort of as gracefully,
gracefully as possible.
But the thing I've seen
happen in the market
because I mentor
students who are going on
to get their first jobs
is that data scientists,
a lot of people put
that above data analysts
and certainly in pay
that happens a lot.
But you have a lot of companies
now treating a data analyst
role and calling a data
scientist to generate
more sort of interest in it.
And so again, focus on
what is it that you're
asked to be doing to do?
What are the skills
that are needed?
But you know, if you have
a LinkedIn alert up now,
like put both on it, I
think that's prudent.
Yeah, I agree it depends
entirely on the company.
My experience is,
I'll call it analyst.
You know, most a
lot of companies
I see have analyst positions
as part of a function.
So an analyst within the
marketing team or analysts
within the operations
team where they'll
be responsible for using data
to help improve the operations
or just, you know, work
within that function.
And oftentimes they
will have, you know,
SQL skills or maybe some
other skills like R or Python.
But generally they typically
work with, you know, excel,
which is a great I love Excel.
I use it all the time.
So that's what I see
in terms of analysts.
And then separately, I see, I'll
call it by developers and data
scientists.
You know, there's a lot
of overlapping skills.
They're writing a lot
of skill, of course,
and automating the data flow.
The distinction being
the by developers
are primarily about building
and publishing reports, reports
in whatever fashion, whether
it's files or dashboards
or what have you,
whereas data scientists
tend to also have in
addition to that, you know,
the statistical modeling and
insight responsibilities.
So those are the three
main areas that I see.
And so it's great.
I was kind of hoping
that all four of you
would land on a very
clear, concise definition
that you all agreed on, and
we could solve this problem
for the rest of the industry,
but it's OK, it's OK.
So I hope that
everybody at home is
like, I think this is all
really valuable information.
And I think this
advice to if you've
got that job notification to
put both titles in because it
will vary by industry and
it's going to vary by company.
So with that, I would
love to think a little bit
about how you go
about shortlisting
a candidate's resume or CV.
So in other words, what
makes someone stand out
to go from that initial?
We've got 500 resumes.
What what do you use
to help make that cut
or make that decision for
who you're going to at least
do that initial phone call with?
So we have a review team.
Yeah, I think that's a
really important thing.
I think it's different
everywhere, right?
So some places
the hiring manager
may have to filter
all of the resumes
as they come in,
whereas in other places,
I think there is kind
of an HR department
or a review team that
makes those decisions.
So I'd love to hear what
your organization uses.
And then once you
get the resumes, kind
of how do you then start
winnowing things down?
So I will say, like
we generally will
start with a list of skills
that we're interested in,
depending on the
position, and then we
look to see if
those are somewhat
contained in the resume.
And it really depends
on the type of job,
like I feel internships are
probably a lot more flexible,
right, where we have like, you
can go out to our internship
website externally
right now and you
can see the different
buckets that you
can apply for an internship.
And so, you know, once you've
applied for that bucket,
that bucket will
go to a review team
and we will looking for
some specific different list
of skills.
And those could be a
wide variety of skills
because we have a whole bunch
of different managers, right?
And so I would say
there's differently
depending on the
type of position
and the type of
interview style going on.
There's kind of a
different process
behind each one of those.
So that one kind of makes
it hard for to answer.
Hope that helps we I'm lucky
to have a talent acquisition
function that helps me first
filter on the technical skills
I tell them to SQL
and R or Python or one
or some other programming
experience, some preferably
quantitative background,
but it doesn't have to be.
It could be a liberal arts
degree on the liberal arts
major.
And then once I
see their resume,
you know, it's I don't want
to see a four page resume
with 1,000 programming skills,
you know, less is more.
I'm looking for depth.
Have you done a few
things really well as
opposed to many
things over time?
Because I'm trying
to build a team where
we have a team of experts
with different expertise.
And so having someone who's
really good at one thing
is really valuable.
So that will complement
someone who's
really good at something else.
That's how I prefer to hire,
but obviously that's just
my personal preference.
I'd say one thing I'd add
that I saw on a few resumes
I thought was super cool,
where I know from an applicant
perspective, it can be hard
to list the programming
languages you're
familiar without feeling
a little fraudulent.
Like, for me, I'm
definitely stronger and are,
but I know some Python.
But if I just put Python
as a language on my resume,
it could feel misleading.
I'm not like an expert
Python programmer.
I'm more like
basic, intermediate.
So rather than spelling out all
those with the levels I saw,
I've seen, like on a sidebar,
like a nice graph that's almost
like a bar chart of competency.
And so you'd have your top
leg the full bar and then
everything else would be
just arbitrary percentages
for competency.
It might even be like
a Markdown template.
Actually, I think for the
resume that it was generated on.
So check that out.
I thought that was just a
nice way to showcase, hey,
I'm competent in all these
languages to varying degrees
without having a super
long, detailed section.
It's a nice little graph.
So those cool.
Do you have to
specify the scale?
This was not this
is just a visual,
so I guess it depends on how,
how tight you want to be.
That's how you trick people.
I'm a D in my R ability and
then everything else is lower.
Yeah, everything else.
But if you don't label
like, they don't know.
Yeah, I would say, like,
it definitely depends
on their personal perception.
For sure, it was a bad joke.
Yeah, the rank order,
relative strength.
So it's up to you
as the interviewer
to determine like,
OK, what's there?
100 percent?
Yeah with that being said,
I'd like to point out
like resume formatting, right?
Some, you know, some systems
will not take part starts
into the resume format, right?
And a lot of times they will
get printed out on gray scale.
So don't make it all
nice and colorful.
Make make sure like
if you do use color,
that it's going to look
nice in black and white.
Some of my pointers I give to
students because some of them
get really creative and
like, yes, that's wonderful.
I applaud your creativity.
Just make sure it looks
good in black and white, so.
Yeah, the resume
is so important.
Just a reminder that we have
typically 300 to 500 resumes
to get through.
So if you submit a novel, it's
going to just go right past it.
Now, that's some other
things I say, make sure,
like you build
stuff, that somebody
can quickly glance at it in 30
seconds for the first review,
right?
And you've got their
attention, then
they'll go back and look at it
a little bit more detail if they
see something like
that really pops out.
So I always say, like bold
those important things,
you know, and make it about.
Because I've had, like
students will put an order
on their resume.
For example, the last class
I noticed did a lot of this.
Like they'll put
the company name
first and not the position name.
No talk about.
What did you do?
You know, the company
is relative, right?
I mean, great.
This was at Microsoft, but
it's far more important for me
to see what you
did at Microsoft.
So I mean, just me
personally, like
I like that order of like,
I can see what you did
and then I'll look and
see where you did it at.
That's just my own
personal preference,
but it's like because
I want to know about.
I don't want to know about
Microsoft, for example.
I'm using that as an example.
Maybe I shouldn't,
but it doesn't
have to be a data science job
that you've had, you know,
if you had some side
hustle in college.
I think that's really valuable.
It shows initiative,
for example.
Yeah, we've got tons of
tons of great advice,
and I feel like
we talk to Curtis,
I feel like we could do
a whole panel on resumes
and how to build your
data science resume.
We could definitely keep
this conversation going
for another couple of
hours, but we are coming up
on the top of the hour.
Now I have been given the
responsibility to make sure
that we finish on time.
So with that being
said, I do want
to give each of our
panelists a minute or two
to summarize their best advice
for a data science job seeker
or data science manager and,
if applicable, to tell us
about any openings they
may have on their team.
And so to avoid the Oh
gosh, who goes next,
we'll go jerries Katie and
we'll close out with Rhonda.
Yeah, sorry, Jesse.
Can you repeat
the first question
it was what is the best advice?
Yeah so you've
got about a minute
to tell our amazing
community and audience,
what is your advice for a data
science job seeker or data
science manager?
OK yeah, the best thing, I guess
I would want to see from job
seekers that a lot
of folks don't.
I see not doing is
putting in a little effort
to understand the business
that they are applying to,
how it works and what
their products are.
And it's amazing, what, 15
minutes, either downloading it,
if it's free or
looking at recent news
or understanding how
the business is set up
can do to set you
apart from other folks.
Because a lot of folks do come
in sort of expecting tell me
the metrics you care about and
I'll tell you about fancy stuff
you can do with it.
But if I am looking to
grow you within the role
and have you act more
autonomously over time,
I would love to see your
ability to bring that
to the table
instead of me having
to sort of feed you everything.
So there is always,
you know, 10,
20% of candidates
who do that, and I
think they get the
disproportionate number of job
offers out there because
of their ability to do so.
And again, I don't think
it's a ton of effort.
So I think that's something
that can set you apart.
And again, it's a minority
of folks who I think
do this and do this while.
And we're filling a job like
today, I'm sorry, everyone,
but I know you mentioned
like, we can do a plug.
Yeah, we're extending
it up for today.
But if folks see positions at
Sirius xm, pandora, Stitcher
or one big happy family, yeah,
I feel free to reach out.
Let me know, and I can give
you some advice on what
you should apply to and happy
to help you out as I can.
Well, I actually really agree
with that advice, always come
with a list of questions, but
I'll try to make this additive.
So before I forget, we do have
an opening for a senior data
scientist, so head out to dental
and check out our career site
would love to hear from you.
I'd say probably
less so, I guess
relevant at the company
I'm currently at.
We're kind of a mid growth
stage startup, but for sure,
hearing it and some of
Rhonda's answers, et cetera.
Bigger companies.
I think it's tough when
you don't know anybody
who works at the
company, just making
sure somebody sees your resume.
So I'd say the additive advice
I would have maybe is like,
I mean, I am not above
if I'm job searching,
like stalking the recruiting
team at that company
and messaging them
on LinkedIn, right?
Like just making sure some
human sees your resume,
I think can be super important.
If you don't know
anybody there, because it
would be a shame if
it just got tossed out
for some silly reason.
So I try to be super hands
on with all the resumes
we see, so I don't have
that great PhD student
slip through the cracks, but I
think that can happen sometimes
just because of the
sheer volume of resumes
that these team gets teams
get and how many openings they
have.
So try to find a physical
human to message, if you can.
Just a quick plug.
We have two openings,
one for either principal
or leads senior data
scientist position and also
one opening for
senior by developer.
Amwell is a
telemedicine company,
so we have lots of data
in terms of my advice.
I think it's important
to understand
the distinction between having
the technical skills to do
the job of a data scientist.
But then you also
need to make sure
and this has been
mentioned before
that you have the statistics
knowledge as well.
You can perform the tasks
required, right SQL right are.
But if you really
don't understand
what it is the models represent
now that can limit your growth.
So that's my advice.
All right.
So I always have kinds of
advice, but if you're a female,
you can do it.
You can apply for data
science jobs like this thing.
And my second is
always pick something
that you're passionate about.
You'll be far more
interested in it.
Don't just pick a job just
because it's a data science
job.
Pick something that you're
truly enthusiastic about.
And as far as Boeing hiring,
we are always hiring.
We are a global company with
wide, vast, diverse positions
open.
And like, you could work
anywhere from like Spain,
Australia, Singapore to the
u.s., any about anywhere
in the u.s., you could imagine.
Not not everywhere, but
good, diverse positions.
So I'd really encourage you
to look at Boeing careers.
I forget the exact website,
but I always pass it around.
Or you can put it into Google
and you'll find it pop up.
And I would just say, if you
are looking for a job there,
make sure you use a vast
variety of different terms
because for us, it's I am a
data scientist at Boeing that
is technically my skill code.
But we also have
applied statisticians,
applied mathematicians, we
have advanced technologists.
All of those are
similar types of jobs.
We even have data science,
engineering skill code.
We, you know, people
who focus on AI, machine
learning, autonomy systems.
We have library services,
we have health services,
we have our own fire department.
So there's just a wide variety
of job opportunities for you
at the Boeing company.
Awesome that is amazing.
So this is such incredible
advice from all of you.
Thank you so much for sharing
your time and your expertise.
So as we close out our
session, I, of course,
want to thank you personally.
I am going to thank you
on behalf of RStudio
and especially on behalf
of our community, everyone
who is watching live
right now and everyone
who is going to tune in over
the coming weeks and months.
You have been
phenomenal guests and I
know I've learned
a tremendous amount
and I know that everyone
watching has also
learned an incredible amount.
So with that, our
panel conversation
has come to an end.
And I want to wish you
all a phenomenal day
and I hope we can
talk again soon.
Thank you.